I thank you for coming like most of you
I used to be a Java developer for ten
years our twist TDD design patterns
solid principle and then two years ago I
joined big panda and I switched to a
functional Scala and after a while I
realized that the wearer's writing and
reading code was very different
I was thinking way less and in a good
way
so my day as a Java developer would look
like this I would start with some code
and in my mind I have a mental stack and
I start to read a function and it might
want exception it might not so the thing
I have to do is to go with the
implementation see the possible
exception put it in my mental stack and
go on and then I would continue I would
read another function that would go to
the database and again there might be an
exception that might be other kind of
errors so I would go to the
implementation put this in the back of
my mind and continue and again and again
so what happen at the end is basically
overflow right too much stuff to track
and that's something you don't want to
do so I'm gonna give you a few
techniques to avoid that and we're gonna
talk about functions about the data and
then about patterns and then we do a
quick summary and we have questions at
the end so the first tool I'm going to
talk about is function signatures
the way I think about function
signatures this way like a newspaper
send a newspaper
you have articles and you have titles
and a good title should tell you enough
about the content of the article you
should enough to go and read the full
article so a good function signature
should be the same way right so let's
take a look at this function what's
going on here well we have an input it's
an int and we have an output you to
string so the way to visualize this
thing would be like this we have types
right it's this circle right ends and
strings and we have values and values
would be 1 2 3 4 ends or ABC whatever
for Strings and the function is simply
the mapping between those values right
and I don't really need to know anything
about the implementation what matters
here is the function signature when I
see this visual I get the full picture
right so let's take a look at this
function what's going on here to divide
functions it takes two int and it gives
me back an int right I'm dividing two
values and I give it your back 1 and if
I give you 0 I throw an exception so the
way to visualize this thing would be
like this right so I'll give you 2 is 5
& 5 and you'll give me back one I'll
give you 10 and 5 you give me back to
write this visual is straightforward but
what happen if I feed it 0 what happened
to the visual right well this thing
happens why there is an hour that goes
to some value that is not defined
something not natural is going on here
this behind the circle right there is
the
exception thingy and the way right
that's a bad function signature right
you want why is it bad
right why is this function signature bad
well it lies it doesn't tell you the
truth you have to go and read
implementation to understand what it
does and you have to keep this exception
in the back of your mind and that's only
one function imagine a lot of those you
have to change those and you have to put
on top of your mental stack again and
again why you don't want that so the way
to avoid that is to use total functions
total functions are very simple for
every single input they have a
corresponding output so the visual is
very clean right here we have the
increment function I'll give you one you
give me back to give you two you're
giving back three it's very
straightforward the function signature
is trustworthy right it doesn't lie to
me I can just I don't care about
implementation what I care is the
signature here and it tells me the truth
the trust is back and what okay so let's
go back now to the divide function we'll
come back to divide function after we're
just gonna move to the pure function
first this is the same function as
before right the Inc function here
that's the same it's something different
up in here what's different here is it a
total function oh yeah it's the same
function if I give you one key thing
back to but something hell's going on
here there is a printing in the middle
here right and what is this why it
doesn't look so bad right now but it
could be anything instead of printing it
could go to the database and drop the
full database it could launch missiles
the point is I don't know from the
function signature what this function
does again it's lying to me so you have
to go you have to read the function and
then you have to put this in the back of
your mind
this thing is called a side effect so
you want function data side-effect free
and this functioned I call pure
functions right and when you use pure
function you think less about the
implementation what matters is the
function signature not the
implementation all right so let's go
back to this divide function and it's
try to fix it so the way to do it right
is to use this container type called
either and it will tell the reader of
the function that there might be an
error in the in the function right what
is doing basically it's bubbling up the
internal of the function at the level of
the function signature this either type
will tell you on the left side that's
the errors right and on the right side
the good value so now as a reader I
don't have to go and read the
implementation I can just look at the
function signature and that's it I get
the full picture here right we're going
to talk about these container types now
with you the most common ones quickly
right in the standard library in job in
SCARA sorry so one of the most common
one is option so I would have a function
like that which is middle name not
everybody as a mineral name and when I
read this function signature it will
tell me they might be a return value or
they might not right it's all about
readability and to express yourself to
the reader of this function either right
basically this container type just wrap
the simple type right that's what we do
here you see with this brackety thing e
so inside you put the type that you
would like to return and here again it
will tell you this function might return
errors
we have a list and this is a little bit
different it's talking more about the
shape of the output when you read this
function right it will tell you you
might have multiple output values it's a
little bit different than before we
don't talk about errors we talk about
the shape of the output values and then
a future that's also very interesting
future will tell the reader of the
function that the value that is
expecting might be or might not be
available right now it's more about when
this value is available all right so
let's recap quickly we talked about
total functions and now for every input
you have a corresponding output we
talked about pure functions that have no
side effect and then we talked about
container types right we saw how we fix
this divide function with either and you
have to when you use all these
techniques right you get you enrich your
signature right you give a new meaning
to your signature think about the
newspaper right you want a good title
you don't want the reader to go and you
read the for article you just want to
give him a good headline so good
function signatures make you think less
about the implementation that's the
whole point right the mantle stock thing
you don't want to go and read
implementation every time that's what I
used to in Java always I would just to
click on the function everybody is doing
this look look it up what is it doing
you don't want to do that you don't have
to do that when you use total functions
when you use pure functions when use
container types you have good signatures
and you don't have to think about
implementation alright now we're going
to talk about another property of
functions and it's a little bit
different this was a big aha moment for
me in functional programming
it's not so much about if I care about
the implementation but more about how
many ways could you implement the
functions it's very interesting think
about writing the function signature and
I give you a pen right and it could be
10 pens
you don't know how to write this
function there are so many possibilities
so let's take a look at this function
right and this is a parametric function
so we have a parametric type a this
thing tells you in the bracket what it
tells you that you could replace this a
with any type could be a string could be
alone and int a list whatever that's
what you have to think when you see this
parametric type and the question is how
many way
could you implement this thing could you
implement this function of course you
think total functions pure functions we
don't use side effects we don't throw
exceptions and we wish treating
ourselves not to use all this magic
hashcode function to string functions
all this stuff that comes from the
object Java class right so how many ways
2 3 4 what turns out there is only one
way to do it right and what's
interesting here is why is that why is
there only one way to implement this
function so the answer is easy we don't
know anything about a this thing is so
abstract that I don't know its values if
I tell you int right you can draw the
circle of ends in your mind and you know
the value 1 2 3 4 bit if I tell you a
you draw this circle you don't know
its values you don't know any function
on a so you put into a corner here you
have no choice you have to return the
input you have only one way to implement
that
what if I do that what if I enrich the
type signature with a container type
right with list I'm doing a small thing
here I'm just changing this a into a
list of a and I'm returning a list of it
so what I'm telling to the reader is the
shape of the input could be multiple
eight and the output could be multiple
eyes how is it going to affect the
number of implementation how many ways
could you implement this function now
what did it do to the implementation
space well we can implement it a little
bit more right you have a little bit
more possibilities we can switch the
head and the tail we can do some some
stuff but not so many right we can't
sort this thing we don't have any
ordering or nays right we don't sort the
list so what what happen here basically
we just enrich the function signature
with a container type and we get a
little bit more of implementation space
the way for you to write this function
is a little bit more there is a little
bit more ways for you to do it and the
last one would be to do something like
that what would this do to the
implementation space of the function
what did I do here I just remove the a
as a return value and put an int right
and think about it again this int you
can draw it in your mind it's a circle
with the values 1 2 3 4 so how many ways
can you implement this well one can
written 1 2 3 4 5 the number of ends
right so what happened here well what
happened let's think about that we just
jump here to another dimension of number
of implementation that's interesting we
started with something very abstract
with one a right and we are not in one
way
to implement it and then we enrich the
signature with a list we add a little
bit more implementation possibilities
but not so much not so much and we
finished within and we just jumped to
another dimension so what does it mean
this thing
well this notion is called pyometra City
and it's very interesting why is it
important to you because when you use a
parametric function right the more it's
abstract the less way you have to
implement it the less possibilities for
you to make a mistake right it's like
giving you a blank page and I'll give
you one thing or if I give you 10 pens
so what you have so many choice that you
could make mistakes but here when you
use permit Rissa tea to more abstract it
is the less you have to think about how
to implement the function right it's not
so much about what implementation is
with the function signatures it's more
about for you as a developer how to
write the code right you have to think
less about it makes you think less about
your implementation so we talked about
functions right about total functions
pure functions parametric functions but
of course functional programming is
programming with functions but we all
know that software is not only functions
right function like software is about
designing data and designing behavior
it's beyond functions right there is
something else there if you want to
build a full-fledged application you
can't just start writing functions it's
it's not going to work out and is there
a way we're going to start with data so
is there a way to encode data that would
make you think less that we have this
property for you as a developer to think
less in a good sense right so the way to
do it is to use some types
some types is a way to encode data so
it's very simple here we have a
developer trait which is basically an
interface and you would have a DevOps
which extends this developer trait then
you would have a full stacker with a
salary net and then you would have an ml
developer with a salary in long and what
does it really mean this thing right why
would you want to encode the data this
way why would you want to use this some
type button this button some types is
also referred as algebraic data types so
keep this in mind and why would you want
to do that why would you want to use
that why is it a good thing well first
the compiler will be with you when you
use this thing right if I were to
function say hi that takes a developer
and I pattern match on it if I forget a
case the compiler will tell you you
forgot the ML case right something that
is extremely powerful in Java the
compiler will only check the syntax if
you forget a semicolon or like a bracket
well in Scala it will check the
correctness for you something that is
very powerful a lot of functional
programmers will tell you you know if it
compiles it works well comes from that
because the compiler is not only
checking the syntax but checking the
correctness of your code that's why they
would say that also this ADT's these
subtypes were all the immutable so you
don't have to think so much about
concurrency bugs shared mutable states
you can't change this stuff right this
developer you can't really change if you
want in your instance of it you have to
create a new one so you don't have to
think about all this possible mutable
short state
all right so what about this function
the load use of function but you've seen
it in a lot of code bases you know these
strings everywhere this ends
these Long's you don't really know what
it is right here this load user could
use the ID could use the email you don't
know you want to encode your data to
make you think less about all these
possibilities you want the compiler to
work for you and the way to put some
domain knowledge in your values right I
want this load user function to take an
email so the way to do it is to use
value classes and basically this value
classes is just a simple pattern you
wrap your simple type and you extend any
var and now you get a nice type right my
lord user takes an email what is it
doing what is why this thing important
because you put in two main knowledge
inside your types the compiler now will
be behind you
to catch you when you make a mistake you
don't have to think so much about what
these strings don't you know what they
mean this doubles is it money is it time
no one knows right but if you type it
properly with value classes you don't
have to think about that all right let's
recap we talked about ADT's right about
some types and how they encode immutable
data and how the compiler will check the
correctness of your code when you forget
an edge case there is basically
basically there is normal edge cases you
don't have to think about forgetting and
a case the compiler will do it for you
we talked about value classes and now
how we can just put domain knowledge
inside the types so the compiler will
also help us to write code that is more
correct
so all these techniques right about data
will make you think less about the
correctness you don't have to think so
much
before the compiler will check the
correctness for you something that I
believe is extremely powerful and Java
doesn't give you right all right so we
talked about functions we talked about
data and what's left or patterns right
the way to design software in the old
world would be like that design patterns
we all shred it
it's what what are these design patterns
well
the elaborate class hierarchies actually
they have the good value right this
stuff if you used it you see that it's
very valuable all these buttons do
emerge in your software you do see them
you do see abstract factories visitors
and stuff like that but you know they
sit in a book somewhere right every team
that you worked on I'm sure you've seen
it will implement these buttons in a
different way also when you start
learning those it might have happened to
it happened to me you start using them
everywhere so what you get is all these
over-engineered
code bases it takes a long time to
internalize these patterns so is there a
way right and to fit this in your mentor
stack all these patterns it is not that
easy right so is there a way to design
patterns to have patterns that make you
think less about that would make you
think less right you won't have to fit
all this stuff in your mind so let's go
back to the function world and try to do
patterns at the functional level okay so
how would you spot patterns the old way
well you would look at your code you
will refactor and then you will see a
lot of similarities so here is the
it's exactly the same thing you have to
look at your functions and try to
support the similarities right and what
are the similarities at the function
level Wow the number of parameters the
number of outputs the type right if the
tides are the same the shape of the
functions so here I have 1 plus 1 Aiken
can't be least 1 2 3 that I want to come
cut with least 4 5 6 so what does all of
this stuff has in common let's try to
find a pattern here well they have the
same number of parameters right I give
you 2 inch you give me back one I give
you 2 strings you give me back one right
so that the same number of time it is
also the type is the same right
I'll give you int + int you give you
back in need that's the type of
similarities you have to pay attention
now right it's very different from
design patterns now you don't look at
classes in IR keys you just look at your
functions at your types at your
parameters and you try to see
similarities so this stuff you would
refactor it to this type of function
right combined ends I'll give you two
int you'll give me back one combined
strings the same I'll give you two of
strings you'll give me back a string
something with lists and what is the
essence of this stuff right what is what
transpire I love this pattern
how can you capture that well it's this
thing right you can feel it it's one a
and another and I'll give you back an h1
type two of the same types and I give
you back what
and I would you encode this thing in
code how would you do that well the way
to encode this is to use type classes
that's the way to extract the
similarities at the function level and
type classes are not classes they are
trait right it's an interface they are
my parameter we see here a and the
function that we wanted to extract here
this combined thing is here it takes two
A's and give you back an A it's very
abstract
we don't have an implementation but we
can fill that this is the right encoding
and this is a parametric function that's
the tool for the job right a parametric
function it's very abstract right so all
right now I have this stuff what I do
with it right what do I do with this how
do I use this thing right it's so
abstract well one way to do it would be
to implement instances so it's very
tedious right it's manual you just doing
you and you override this combined with
your own type so here we do for internet
and we'd be and which supply the
implementation for combining to it here
we decided to do a plus same thing for
Strings right I override this combined
method with string and string and I give
you back my implementation of it you can
also do it for your own types right here
I created my own class foo and it takes
an INT and a string so I can also
implement the combined method for foo
right it's my own implementation and I
tell you how to do it so we take the
first parameter and the second one and
we give you back a new foo this stuff
also you can pay attention use and
places that's the to wait a bit so why
we use implicit because we want to
summon the stuff and get it magically
with the implicitly syntax right it's
very nice you see I give a and B I get a
B 1 in 1 I get 2 and same thing for food
great ok that's a nice refactoring it's
very nice but did we really gain
anything here did we gain something
right from the old way
well first of all we don't use
la siroque is right all this scary like
XML stuff just doesn't exist anymore
right
we work at a function level right so we
talk we don't you we didn't use any
inheritance here right we just choose
overloading we didn't use inheritance
and like design pattern this stuff as a
name right - one of the strongest aspect
of design pattern is the other name so
if I'm in a team and I tell my coworker
I used an abstract Factory it's supposed
to know what it is the same thing with
these functions with this pattern these
patterns of a name and this combine of
all thing which would that we just
discovered it's official name is a mano
it right so this stuff right all this
and that's not the only pattern to it
with a lot of these patterns and a mano
it it's the same thing you see the
combined method is the exactly the same
thing right takes two of the same give
you back one of the same it's the same
trade also it has an empty we will need
that later but basically for the plus
right for in the empty would be zero
right you want one plus zero equal one
so you need this so great but you know
what well you don't have to know this
stuff and you don't have to discover it
you can just import them that's
something that is extremely powerful
right you can do that you can import
mono it from cats opens ecology we can
also import the instances right you
remember I wrote them right for ins for
Strings where you don't have to do that
anymore
from the library and think about it
right think about our power for this
thing is when you want assign pattern
everybody would go to the book and would
implemented its own way there is no
libraries for design patterns just does
not exist here not only you have the
check interfaces you also have the
instance someone very smart wrote this
code for you you just have to take it
and to use it right so if I import this
stuff I can do the same thing I get this
magical combined method on one on the
value itself I got this combined method
I can just use it one combined one two
same thing on string I did not have to
write any code distinct em for free
right same thing for list 1 2 3 4 5 6
this thing is great and of course that's
one pattern but as Rob Norris would say
everything sufficiently polymorphic and
useful already exist what does it mean
it means everybody that worked on these
patterns why they already discovered for
you ok there is a big community out
there that worked on those already and
just supply this stuff for you in this
libraries you just have to look up the
documentation take what you need and put
it in your project that's something that
is very powerful that does not exist in
the old world these design patterns
don't have that you don't have this
libraries with implementation to use and
you can just go and take what you need
also because these patterns are so
common right is mono there is a huge
ecosystem building on top of this
libraries all these type classes well
you can also get you CDs full class that
we define before and I had to write
manually the implementation if I want I
can use this library called kittens I
just imported and it will magically
figure out what is my mono it instance
it will give you magically this combined
method for free right that's very
powerful all these libraries work with
this functional pattern so you get all
this stuff for free and this is an
example right you could add what
you read about tight glasses it's not
only that you get this free thing where
it is combined you also get a lot of
what's called the right function so
let's take a look at our model again the
combined method that we discovered is
called the function that the definitive
function where it's defining the type
class but we also have and this the
right function here is for example
combined all these top you also get free
and that's a very interesting I just
want to show you the implementation you
don't have to implement it right because
you get it for free but that's the way
to implement it think about parametric
City what we talked about before the way
I mean not so many right you know you
have to use this empty and combined look
at this function it's only defined in
terms of these two abstract methods
right about empty and combined you know
you have to use them you know you get a
lot of inputs so you know and you have
to get one so there is only one thing
you can do is to take all these values
and holden that's it to write this
function is so easy because you don't
have so many options
that's parametric City in action right
there so you can just import this stuff
and you get this combined all for free
right now I can combine lists alright I
can give you one two three I will get
six ABC I will get ABC and Foods and it
works
right so let's wake up quickly about
this functional pattern how do you
encode functional patterns while you use
type classes these type classes of
parametric function and also the way to
implement these type classes would be to
write instances we saw that you can use
cats or Scalzi
and import it directly into your
codebase and you don't even have to
write your own instances this thing will
give it for free also we saw that we
have all these libraries that build on
top of all these functional patterns and
something very important right all this
knowledge all this functional knowledge
you keep it with you as opposed to
spring or Ivan eight or whatever
framework these things does not get all
right all these patterns two way to
encode functions well these things is
forever whatever language you use
framework these things stay with you
right throughout your career you grow
into it and you don't have to think each
time when you move to a new team I need
to learn this and you to learn that well
this stuff is universal right so it's do
a quick summary we talked about function
signatures now you can use total
functions pure functions and container
types to write great function signatures
so you don't have to think about what is
the implementation the mental stack
again you want it free of clutter we
talked about ADT's right about data and
how to encode data in a way that would
make you think less about the
correctness of your code the compiler
will catch all your edge cases and then
we finished with design part with
functional patterns and now they would
make you think less about you don't even
have to think about the implement you
get them for free from all these
libraries you also don't have to think
about all these class hierarchies that
used to be in this all design patterns
you just get them for free from cuts and
Scalzi so use this stuff right think
less about your code thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]